their paddy fields look lush and green
but in reality these farmers are
struggling on may 6 last year they were
forced to go organic overnight and their
production has plummeted since
i am very sad that poor people are
facing huge problems now
kumara megastana lost his job as a
construction worker after prices of
cement skyrocketed all he and his family
have is a few paddy fields to feed
themselves
by buying expensive fertilizer on the
black market he hopes to increase
production
i'm working so hard but it feels as if
it is all for nothing the government
gave us organic fertilizer but it's not
good with good fertilizer we got a lot
of rice but now it's just a fraction
before i bought good fertilizer my
harvest went down with fifty percent
six months after their dramatic decision
the government lifted the ban by then
the country was already in its worst
economic crisis since its independence
70 years ago this is one of the painful
legacies of former president gotabaya
rajapaksa's policies the agricultural
sector has nearly collapsed in just
three years sri lanka had long been an
exporter of rice has now been forced to
import their staple food
the imports are costing the country
dearly here in the hills around candy
sri lanka's second largest city all of
the country's current crises come
together
to take their rice and vegetables to the
market farmers need fuel which is in
short supply those who are lucky enough
to find fuel to buy find the markets
nearly empty because traders and buyers
face a lack of fuel too
we can't rely on this business anymore
if we manage to bring 500 kilos of
vegetables from our farms here there are
no customers to buy it and while the
price has gone up for example 500 rupee
a kilo at the end of the day i am forced
to sell for 200 rupees i keep losing
money and the impending disaster
professor marambe was sacked as a
government advisor after he had worn the
import ban was a recipe for disaster
it's a man-made disaster very
unfortunately it's too late but still we
have some hope that we are in the
correct path this is not going to say
organic agriculture is bad i mean nobody
should get that impression right they
are all parallel lines but we are
looking at countries food security not a
food security of a small group of people
he says domestically grown rice will run
out in a few months leaving whoever
takes over as president a massive
problem how to pay for imported rice to
prevent a humanitarian disaster when the
government has run out of foreign
currency step faster al jazeera candy
sri lanka